[Music]
which camera do you want me to look at
so hey wait are we talking about whether
technology's good or bad
i think that's too simplistic because
the argument is we know technology can
be good or bad are we too worried about
technology or like how worried should
you be or what's the right amount of
worry something like that
[Music]
the 21st century this is what it was
supposed to look like
according to the jetsons at least flying
cars weekends in space and robots that
would carry out domestic chores
here we are in the 2020s and we're
expecting it to be like blade runner and
you know where are the flying cars
actually there are some flying cars i'm
not sure i'd want to go in them just yet
but they are here but i think if you
know someone visited today 2020s from
the fairly recent past they'd be amazed
at what we have
like airplanes that travel to the other
side of the world in a matter of hours
in the past people took months or years
to get to some parts of the world and
had a pretty good chance of dying on the
way rather than wait weeks for a letter
people can communicate with one another
at the click of a button a savior in the
covet lockdown era almost every day she
waits here by the
mailbox technology is getting better but
what about our relationship with it
well i think we have a love-hate
relationship with technology we like the
good parts and we like them so much that
it becomes part of our lives and then we
kind of stop noticing it i mean the
classic side of a mature technology is
that you only notice it when it stops
working
and the pandemic has really made us
realize how important it is for
technology to work because we're using
it now more than ever before
before the pandemic americans consumed
digital media for six hours 49 minutes
each day in 2020 that went up by over an
hour
during lockdown the internet was a
lifeline for businesses and enabled
social connections
technological advances also facilitated
rapid vaccine development
however recent years have shown how
quickly optimism about technology can
turn to pessimism
in 2010 2011 the arab spring was
happening and people were like talking
about the power of social media to
spread democracy and everyone was very
very optimistic about it and of course
that's not what happened
the same technology that galvanized
people and gave the world cute cat
videos
also disseminated isis beheadings that
spread extremism and fake news that
undermined confidence in vaccines it's
not just that we're worried about the
consequences of it it's also this really
dramatic contrast between what we
thought we were going to get and what we
actually got
it's easy to make starry-eyed
predictions about the wonders of
technology but in reality unforeseen
consequences often dampen our view of it
look back at history and it's clear that
humanity has swung between being
optimistic and pessimistic about
technology
seeing the repeated pattern is key
let's take a journey back in time
the victorian era was a period of rapid
technological transition when many
world-changing innovations first
appeared
they had to get used to not having
things that could go faster than horses
to having things like steam trains and
telegraphs you could suddenly send
messages from from point to point you
know faster than you could send an
object which had not been possible for
the whole of human history
so the world changed over just a period
of a few decades really beyond
recognition and of course the same
thing's happening again now with
computer technology so seeing how people
reacted then can help us understand how
we're reacting now
some people were not all that thrilled
the luddites became a symbol of the
resistance against industrialization
they rebelled against the introduction
of machinery in the textile industry
but were they right to be fair to the
luddites they weren't saying technology
is bad what they were saying was we are
worried that the introduction of this
technology is going to change the
balance of power between
the owners of of capital and the workers
and they were absolutely right so
actually they had a point
the deeply unpopular luddite movement
was met with huge resistance factory
owners took to shooting protesters the
army too was brought in at one point
more british soldiers were fighting the
luddites than against napoleon and the
iberian peninsula
in the end the luddites were crushed
into the pages of history
the industrial revolution was the
greatest wealth creation event in
history it's very dramatic and you've
seen as countries around the world have
industrialized they've become much
richer but at the same time it did you
know change the balance between capital
and labor it did mean that people who
were alive in the 1820s got a bad deal
in the long run everything turned out
better but people had to live in the
short run it was a brutal time of change
that brought about net benefits between
1760 and 1901 in britain life expectancy
rose from 34 to 50 years of age a nearly
50 percent increase and adult literacy
went up by 27 between 1760 and 1850
then in the 1900s came another
technological revolution
the horseless carriage otherwise known
as the automobile in the 1890s there was
this big problem in fast-growing cities
like london and new york that there was
just horse poo piling up everywhere the
automobile shows up and everyone goes oh
thank goodness we'll switch to this and
there are all these predictions made
about how the automobile is going to get
rid of pollution it's going to get rid
of congestion
it's going to be much quieter and there
are going to be fewer accidents and so
people were really optimistic and of
course we now know those predictions
turned out not to be true there's no
horse poo but there's carbon dioxide
coming out of them instead there's lots
of noise and there's lots of congestion
and there are still lots of accidents
can my machine talk to your machine
thanks mary here we go
by the 1970s technology was in every
home making life more comfortable
the future was looking bright you have
it in green certainly here it is but the
cold war was dominating world politics
and with it the prospect of nuclear
annihilation
concern about technology was once again
on the rise
people were worried about technology and
they were worried about several
technologies at the same time
1973 dramatized u.s dependence on
foreign oil the world was going to run
out of oil they were worried about
overpopulation and you know was was
there going to be enough food to feed
everyone it was very much a familiar
sounding litany of technology is running
faster than we can cope
but by the 90s the tune was very
different
this ameritech ad sums it up do you have
a cellular phone
why yes i do oh
so do i
so you've got this pendulum swing from
the 70s to the 90s and suddenly
everyone's really optimistic at the end
of the 90s you get the dot-com boom
where like the internet's going to fix
everything it's going to get rid of
poverty and lead to world peace people
actually believe that because they
thought that people would organize
themselves into sort of online tribes
and there was a guru at mit who said our
children are not going to know what
nationalism is
this utopian view of an online global
community has been replaced by tech doom
mongering at the economist we've come up
with a word to describe the sort of
backlash against technology and against
technology giants and we call it the
tech lash
so how can the world get over its techno
pessimism or tech lash
and move forward in a way that's
cautious but not fearful adventurous but
measured
the pandemic has reminded us of the
upside of modern tech much of which we
had taken for granted
the rapid development of vaccines proves
how science and technology can change
the world for the better so i wonder
whether that might make some people feel
a bit more optimistic about technology
again
at the same time however social media
platforms have been used to spread
misinformation about the vaccines and
there has been an uptick in cyber crime
and ransomware attacks
even criminals it turns out can work
from home
all of which is a reminder of the need
to tread carefully the peso visits with
the tech lash are good things in the
sense that
we're having that debate and we're going
to move forward constructively and if we
learn the lessons of history then maybe
the pendulum won't swing quite so far
next time because we won't have had
quite so many problems next time around
what we don't want is overdoing the the
pessimism and just saying oh this is all
terrible
there's an inconvenient truth the
solution to tech related problems often
involves
more and better tech if you look at
what's happening now with the climate
crisis for example we're really just
kind of finally being faced with the
bill for what we've been doing for the
last 200 years which is the industrial
revolution and now we've actually got to
pay the bill and how we're going to pay
it with more technology
solar panels electric cars
geo-engineering are all possible
technological responses to humanity's
greatest threat climate change
so perhaps there's a better way of
thinking about technology
we need to recognize that technology has
no agency but humans have agency and
it's you know whether a technology is
used for good purposes or bad purposes
is down to the humans who use it
a hammer can be used to build things or
destroy them advanced technology is no
different
part of the problem is that innovation
moves quickly often faster than
regulators and rule makers can keep up
certainly the regulation of technology
it does need to be very nimble like the
technology itself you're never going to
get the rules right first time so we're
starting to see with some technologies
the sort of sandbox approach and this is
where
regulators say we don't know what the
right rules are going to be and we know
that we don't know um so what we're
going to do is we're going to let you
try doing this new thing
but we're going to be looking over your
shoulder all the time and at any point
we can say stop we think this is having
a bad consequence
people fear technology because its
effects are often unknown so mass
perceptions can easily swing between
bright and bleak
these swings between optimism and
pessimism towards technology are nothing
new by recognizing this historical
pattern we may be able to ensure we
don't swing too far in either direction
in the future
we need new ideas to fix big problems
like climate change and if you imagine a
world that looks just the same as it is
now with all of the problems that it has
and you imagine another world where
there's more innovation well i know
which one i'd like to live in
[Music]
i'm tom standage deputy editor at the
economist to read more about our
changing relationship with technology
click the link thanks for watching
you